a new report shows an increase in
computer attacks targeting people's
medical records pro tennis that's a firm
that helps health care companies protect
data says there were 222 hacking
incidents last year now that's up nearly
25 percent from 2017 and all more than
11 million patient records were affected
and awareness shows us how some of those
records are being bought and then sold
on the black market that's not good and
a good morning no it's not good Gale in
addition to your doctor's notes your
medical records can contain sensitive
information like your date of birth
along with credit card and Social
Security numbers as health care
providers store this information
digitally some have left their files
vulnerable to being exposed we spoke
with a victim of medical identity theft
who showed us just how much damage that
can do it was quite a tumultuous decade
of mess the mess started in 2004 for
Brandon Regan when as a young marine he
lost his wallet months later your mother
calls and she says what local
authorities were here looking for you
today
you know regarding this incident which
was a car theft multiple car this
someone posing as Regan was allegedly
stealing cars and getting multiple
medical procedures then the hospitals
came after Regan to pay a collection
agency bill so the first one so this one
is the balance says it's two thousand
two hundred and thirty six dollars the
bills added up to nearly twenty thousand
dollars you tried to get these problems
off your credit report did that work it
worked into the next billing cycle so
this was like a never-ending battle and
not the kind of battle that you and the
Marine Corps are trained to handle yes
ma'am but Gary Cantrell sees it all the
time as head of investigations at the
Health and Human Services Department's
Office of Inspector General every one of
our investigations involves the use of
medical data to commit this fraud he
warns thieves want people's medical
records it's just a treasure trove of
all this information about you
last year alone he says the agency
handled nearly 400 reports of medical
data breaches some of that information
winds up for sale on
internet's dark whip sometimes they're
compromising this data and we don't know
how it's being used when or if it will
be used to compromise those individuals
identities so it's kind of sitting out
there like a time bomb potentially
that's right so how easy is it for
criminals to get hold of patients files
we asked cybersecurity expert gary
miller ski how long did it take us here
to find medical records on the dark web
it took me a few seconds yeah like
literally like three seconds yeah this
seller offered children's health records
for sale USA kids full records from a
pediatrician from the years 2000 to 2014
another posted an entire hospital's
worth of files healthcare database from
Georgia three hundred ninety seven
thousand patient records it's a three
hundred and ninety seven thousand
patient records in a health care
database is what they're selling exactly
so how are they getting the records
their quote unquote product description
says breached a very large hospital
recently exactly so the bees are you
saying somebody hacked into this
hospital and here's the records if you
want to buy them for twenty six grand
exactly they want to monetize these
records quickly and they're actually
offering them at a discount compared to
other prices I've seen on the dark web
social security numbers sell for a buck
and credit card info goes for up to a
hundred and ten dollars but Experian
reports full medical records can command
up to one thousand dollars because
they're an identity thieves dream so I'm
looking at the details right it says
date of birth place of birth credit card
details social security number your
address emails the three-digit code on
the back of the card right and so this
is really all they need if they buy this
then they can become you and hackers
have stolen millions of records breach
at anthem insurance affected seventy
eight million people and a hack at UCLA
health exposed more than four million
patient records despite that a 2017
survey of health care providers found
just sixteen percent reported having a
fully functional cybersecurity program
one of our most important missions is to
mitigate that vulnerability as quickly
as possible and that means
indicating with those individuals who
oversee the systems as for Brandon Regan
the crook who stole his identity served
time in prison but 15 years later Regan
says he still hasn't been able to undo
all of the damage that hospital may
still have his information in his blood
died under my name at that hospital but
that's kind of worrisome this is a
little weird to think because of
situations like that experts we spoke
with say it's a good idea to request a
copy of your medical files now to clear
up any confusion if your records are
altered later due to medical identity
theft which is a lot of information on
the medical records I never thought
about your three-digit code is on your
medical record a lot of the onus on us
right as usual yeah this is the thing
right so if doctors and hospitals
offices don't have adequate security
they communicate with other entities in
the medical world then you know they all
do have different security systems
there's a mental for heck and that's
such a shame because having digital
medical records has been such a benefit
to so many people it's so convenient
right but it comes with the writs until
they steal your identity thanks so much